[Music]
Prince Harry and Megan Markel have just
settled into their new home near Windsor
Castle awaiting the birth of their first
child but they may be packing their bags
again soon the Sunday Times in London
reports that the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex could move to Africa if it
happens their royal duties would include
would involve charity work and promoting
Britain in Tia's tyub is outside
Buckingham Palace India's good morning
good morning and it is a beautiful day
here outside of Buckingham Palace as we
wait for the latest news on the royal
bertha royal birth that we're hearing
could come any day now but it's the mum
and dad to be Harry and Megan that
everybody's talking about we're hearing
that they could be making a major move a
move so major they could cross
continents Easter service set st.
George's Chapel on Sunday a tradition
for the royal family and for Prince
Harry one of his last engagements before
he becomes a dad his pregnant wife Megan
sat out the service but earlier in the
day the Sunday Times newspaper reported
the duke and duchess of sussex are not
only gearing up to become new parents
but very possibly for another new role
this time in Africa Roy Anika co-wrote
the article for The Sunday Times there's
no doubt that Harry and Megan I think
want a bit of freedom from the UK they
want a little bit of freedom from the
institution Harry and Megan already have
a special connection to the continent I
most persuade her to come and join me in
Botswana with each other under the stars
one of the diamonds in Megan's
engagement ring is from Botswana in 2017
Harry told Town and Country magazine
this is where I feel more like myself
than anywhere else in the world when
Princess Elizabeth was newly Wed she and
Prince Philip spent long periods of time
between 1949 and 1951 in Malta the Queen
has spoken about that as being among the
happiest years of her life Harry and
Megan's move abroad is being described
by courtiers as giving him a chance of
their multi moment
we reached out to the palace to get more
on that they're not saying a whole lot
but they did say to CBS News that Harry
and Megan are in the early stages of
planning their future which could
involve the move abroad but right now
they're just focusing on the birth of
their baby which could come any day now
Nora when all right empty house tie up
in London thank you you know what's a
big good because right now you know
they've just moved to Windsor I'm told
they redecorated the house and right now
they just want to concentrate on having
the baby having a healthy baby and get
settled you know the place has a yard
where the baby can play they're really
excited about that so if this happens
and that's a big if I don't believe it's
happening anytime soon I know when
you're when you're about to have a baby
all you want to do is nest at home yeah
because you know that waddle is real
yeah that pregnancy waddle is real and
you just want the baby to come back
right they just want to concentrate on
being home in Windsor and enjoying this
baby boy or baby girl I can't wait to
see what this baby's gonna look like I'm
you know wait for that first picture